jeff bezos travels to space and
redistributionists are fighting mad
about it
rand paul and anthony fauci go to war
and lockdown advocates are eager to
stymy freedom thanks to the delta
variant i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't let big tech track what you do
anonymize your web browsing at
expressvpn.com
ben speaking of which the last thing you
want is other people monitoring
what you do let's say that you're a
proud gun owner and you want to talk on
social media about the right to bear
arms well chances are that your post
will probably be flagged by a content
moderator and that could end up being
funneled over to the government to fight
back against having your voice censored
by both big tech and big government
i recommend express vpn see the problem
with big tech not only do they attempt
to censor you they also track what you
do online what you're searching for the
videos you watch
everything you click they can then match
your activity to your true identity
using your device's unique
ip address when i use expressvpn they
can't see my ip address at all
my identity is anonymized by a secure
vpn server plus
expressive vpn encrypts 100 of my
internet data for protection from
hackers and eavesdroppers
expressvpn is by far the best vpn i have
tried it is the
number one vpn as rated by cnet and
wired and countless other tech
publications what i love most about
expressvpn it couldn't be easier to use
the app has one button you tap it and
now you are protected it is indeed
that simple so stop letting big tech and
big government censor and track you
defend your rights protect yourself at
expressvpn.com
ben that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
to get three months for free
expressvpn.com
ben to learn more alrighty so yesterday
something very cool happened to jeff
bezos who of course is the owner
of amazon founder of amazon he went up
into space
is a very very cool thing right this is
a unique
moment in human history when we have
moved beyond
simple governments taking human beings
to space we now have two separate
billionaires
in the past two weeks who have gone into
either very very low space or into
slightly higher space and elon musk is
planning to go into full orbit
and the idea here is to eventually
privatize space travel which would be
super duper cool i mean that's a really
neat thing
here's a little bit of the video of blue
origin origins the jeff
bezos rocket firing him and a couple of
friends into space
hey you can see uh the dr evil style
phallic rocket flying directly up
into space it would have been good
aesthetically if they had made some
changes but
there it is it's uh flying into space
and that is pretty cool i mean
that is a human being who uh has um
you know a lot of money at stake as well
as his life going into space as a
civilian
and the idea here is going to be to
lower the price of space travel
down dramatically and that actually is
what is likely to happen here
according to reason.com there's every
reason to believe the democratization of
space travel is upon us bezos branson
elon musk have already delivered on that
promise in other sectors unless the
government manages to screw things up
following the pattern of commercial air
travel in the 20th century a novelty for
billionaires today may well be
accessible to the ordinary rich and then
to the middle class
soon enough also the billionaires say
they are taking a long-term view one day
the capacity to get off the planet
cheaply and at scale
could be humanity's salvation but it's
not just what they want or what they
envision that matters you know we'll
figure out
as the market evolves exactly what is
important about
all of this i know that people from
spacex are openly talking about the idea
of building a moon base to mine
the moon for resources by the end of the
decade which is really super cool stuff
by the way they've already driven down
the cost of getting a kilogram into low
earth orbit by 44 fold because they're
building a competitive industry
where companies are actually competing
to lower the cost on getting things into
space and that does matter
for even things as convenient as your
cell phone coverage satellite coverage
if you can get satellites into space
more cheaply this is going to bring down
prices for a lot of technologies
here on earth one thing that bezos was
suggesting was the ability to
essentially fire pollution
off earth right if there are heavy
industries that produce
for example nuclear waste and you have
no place to put that could you actually
just
throw that off into space yeah it's it
it doesn't really matter in other words
who gets to space first what does matter
is that we are
creating a very cool competitive
industry here and we are doing it with
private dollars which really does matter
that now this doesn't mean that the left
isn't mad about all this left is super
mad
about all of this because according to
the left all wealth is collectively
owned
so you have bernie sanders for example
tweeting out about this
he tweeted quote here on earth just
contour on the planet half our people
live paycheck to paycheck
people are struggling to feed themselves
struggling to see a doctor but hey
the richest guys in the world are often
out of space yes
it's time to tax the millionaires okay
so first of all
all net taxes in the united states all
net taxes in the united states after
transfer of government benefits
come from people who are very wealthy
all of them not some of them
all of them the notion that people at
the top end of the income bracket are
not paying their quote unquote fair
share is just a lie it is an overt and
silly lie
and the reality is that if bernie
sanders really wanted to pay for his
vast blowout social programs he would
have to tax people at the same rates
that the tax people in the scandinavian
countries
he so loves which means radically
increasing taxes on the middle class
which by the way bernie sanders is not
averse to doing
okay but jeff bezos pays a lot of taxes
he spends a lot of money
paying a lot of taxes and him using his
wealth in order to foster a brand new
industry is actually really cool because
here is the alternative
we could as a country spend vastly more
money than jeff bezos just spent
in order to do the exact same kind of
stuff by siphoning away your taxpayer
dollars how much money did it cost you
to send jeff bezos to space the answer
is it cost you no money
you bought products from amazon you
subscribed to amazon prime
in return you got value then he used the
profit that he derived from that to do
something cool
that's number one none of your business
number two something that actually does
benefit humanity i've said this over and
over and over
now bill gates has the bill gates
foundation he gives away hundreds of
millions of dollars
jeff bezos yesterday gave away like 200
million dollars
he has done more good for the world in
building amazon than in any of the
charity that he just gave
the reality is that in a free
functioning marketplace the stuff that
we do
together namely the transactions that we
engage in consensually
those are much more beneficial to us and
to the world at large than people simply
signing checks
which is something the left simply can't
fathom here jeff bezos yesterday
saying this in maybe the most awkward
possible way he sort of suggested
that everybody else was paying for his
flight to space in one sense this is
right in one sense this is just a
complete misspeak
i want to thank uh every
amazon employee and every amazon
customer
because you guys paid for all this so
seriously for every amazon customer out
there
and every amazon employee thank you from
the bottom of my heart very much
it's very appreciated okay in reality
did they actually pay for him to go to
space only in the sense that when you
buy something at the grocery store you
paid for the grocery store owner's car
right they they didn't pay for him to go
to space it wasn't like he just seized
their cash and then used it to go to
space
right he actually paid them a salary the
money from the amazon employees
only came from the extra productivity
that they create
because he is taking the risk of paying
them right okay but because people don't
understand economics
this means that for some odd reason they
have a tendency to trust the federal
government
when they should not the reality is that
we should be trusting private industry
to do all the things that make life
better because
historically it is private industry that
has made life better not really
government governments have existed
since time immemorial governments all
over planet earth have existed forever
the question is not whether government
exists or whether government decides to
throw bread at the people as they did in
ancient rome the question is really
whether there are industries that
develop an economy strong enough to
actually make
products and services that are better
one of the great ironies of people like
bernie sanders complaining about very
rich people spending their money to go
to space
is that bernie sanders is very much in
favor of the fact that the federal
government has now seized and siphoned
away 22 trillion dollars in wealth
over the course of the last 50 years in
order to reduce the poverty rate in the
united states by about zero
that doesn't bother him at all because
of course it is the high-minded use of
the money
that bernie sanders cares about more
importantly it's people like bernie
sanders controlling the flow of the
money that bernie sanders cares about
but the ancillary benefits of market
transactions that make the world better
that's the stuff we should be focusing
on we should want more of this not less
of this
if you ever want to be able to travel to
space it ain't going to be because the
federal government makes that possible
it is truly incredible that the same
people who are complaining about
richard branson and jeff bezos spending
their own money to go to space and elon
musk
building a space industry those same
people are like you know what we should
do technologically if i had your money
you know what i'd do i'd build a
high-speed rail
monorail okay who do i trust the
monorail gang over here the people love
amtrak and just want to spend more money
on higher speed amtrak cause we must
have high-speed rail
a full-on 19th century technology you
know from 250 years ago
or should we you know maybe focus in
on the new technologies and more
importantly allow people to spend their
own private wealth on that i mean it's
the coolest thing ever
it is excellent the private industry has
decided to advance
science and advance the the
possibilities of humankind this way
and that you don't have to pay for it
that's pretty damned awesome
again people who value government over
private industry simply don't understand
either government or private industry
i'll get some more of this in just one
second first
let's talk about your sleep quality so
if you want a good sleep and night it is
not just your mattress
it's not just the temperature in your
room is your sheet quality so i know
that you probably just went down to your
local
store and you picked up whatever is the
highest thread count very bad way of
shopping for sheets the reality is what
you need
our bull and branch sheets experience
uncompromising comfort with the
best-selling 100 organic
cotton signature hem sheets the
cloud-weight supersoft sateen weave gets
softer with every single wash actually
gets better over time
it's crafted to the highest standards
and attention to detail from sourcing to
packaging
it's the perfect balance of weight and
breathability to pamper warm or cool
sleepers
through any season give your bed the
white house treatment with sheets that
three presidents have fallen
in love with i love them as well in fact
i like bowling brand sheets so much
that's pretty much all i sleep on
bowling branch is dedicated to quality
every single step sheets are designed
and manufactured for maximum comfort and
durability no cutting corners
no middlemen between you and bowlin
branch so you get luxury quality for the
very fairest
price to experience an entirely new
standard of comfort visit
bullanbranch.com get 15
off your first set of sheets with promo
code shapiro that is b-o-l-l and branch
dot com
promo code shapiro bowl and branch dot
com promo code shapiro
so one of the great things about private
industry handling space travel is that
you don't end up with the guns versus
butter discussions that you have to have
at the governmental level
after the united states sent a man to
the moon in 1969.
we basically started cutting the space
program right after that because there
are a bunch of people
on the left who said you know what we
don't need to go to the moon anymore
there's no purpose what do we care about
space we have enough problems here at
home
well when you have one taxpayer dollar
to spend and you have to decide whether
to buy off constituents
or whether to advance science via nasa
usually it's a pretty easy call for
members of the political class
but the nice thing about private
industry is you don't control it so if
they decide to go do something ex
uber cool with regard to technology
whether it is developing cell phones
forwarding the internet or going to
space that is a zero cost
to you thing it is a value add
and the fact that people fail to
understand this is beyond me
understand that taxes are a way of
siphoning away from people
who are not harming you and are in fact
helping you with their development of
technology
toward people who simply want to buy
votes with your cash
this is your this should be your first
suspicion when you hear people like
bernie sanders shout out about taxing
the billionaires
who spends the money better jeff bezos
or bernie sanders who's never on a
popsicle stand
who's who do you think is going to be
forwarding the interests
of better products and better services
jeff bezos who literally has provided
millions of jobs across the globe and
provided a better life
for hundreds of millions of people i
mean i use amazon every day i'm sure so
do you
who do you think is going to better your
life more jeff bezos with money
or bernie sanders with money whose
entire history of spending money comes
down to buying lake houses with your
taxpayer dollars
who do you think i'm con honestly i'm
constantly shocked
at the fact that all these people who
yell at billionaires and millionaires
they think that the people who are best
positioned to control the money are a
bunch of morons who have never run
a business it's it's it's beyond me
why would you like i wouldn't even trust
a businessman to run a business where he
has no level of expertise so you're
trusting people who have never run a
business
at all to handle your money and
determine where that money is going to
go
when you siphon money away from the
private sector and into the public
sector it becomes less efficient when
you take money away from people who are
entrepreneurial and you put it in the
hands
of people whose sole job it is to buy
off constituents
and to create particular dependent
classes
the money is just gone this is why we
have seen slow growth in the united
states historically speaking when you
regulate business
when you take money away from business
this is why we are going to see after
all of this inflationary growth
after we see joe biden blow out
trillions of dollars
after we see this regulatory the
regulatory schemes he wants to put in
place
this is why even joe biden is predicting
the united states for the next decade is
going to grow at below a two percent gdp
rate
okay and yet joe biden's solution to
that take more money out of the private
sector
they support asking the wealthiest one
percent of americans in corporate
america
not to pay more than she just began to
pay their fair share just step up a
little bit
the idea that 50 largest corporations in
america
pay no tax ex i i think people should be
able to be
millionaires and billionaires if they
have the ideas but lord's sake the idea
let's start paying your fair share
again it's just a lie that they're not
paying their fair share and number two
it's not about who's pa it just
demonstrates really that
in the end democratic policy is not it
really is not
about forwarding any sort of collective
good it is about punishing people who
earn wealth
i mean barack obama made this perfectly
clear in 2008 he was running for
president
who specifically asked if raising the
capital gains tax rate
lowers the amount of government revenue
that is brought in
because people invest less are you still
for it and he said yes for purposes of
fairness
it is a childish mentality when it comes
to economics it's a childish mentality
when it comes to life
people who have more money than you are
not worse people than you and you are
not entitled to their money
most of us in fact will spend our lives
in different income brackets
most of us will spend our lives in the
bottom income bracket and the middle
income bracket maybe the top income
bracket maybe back to the middle income
bracket
year on year our incomes differ pretty
radically in fact if you want to look
at the factor that plays most into
wealth aggregation
it's age people get wealthier as they
get older because they have more asset
bases
they've spent more years in the
workforce and yet the notion seems to be
from the left that when billionaires
spend moneys in ways that you don't like
you should have control over that
if matthew miller who is an msnbc
analyst
saying quote watching nasa takeoffs when
i was a kid with such a moment of
national pride and unity having them
replaced by billionaire vanity flights
is one of the more depressing
touchstones of this era
this is the stupidest thing i've ever
heard so you're more proud when the
government
spends a bunch of your money to send
people to space than when you get to
watch an american
who built an american company and in the
process built literally hundreds of
thousands of american jobs
use that money in order to do the same
thing that nasa did except cheaper this
is what pisses you off
truly amazing stuff because honestly i
think in the end
what what so many people want is
government control
it's the government control is the
excuse it is not that they want
government control because they want a
better life
it is not that they want government
control because they feel that
billionaires
are doing something nefarious with their
wealth there's nothing nefarious about
going to space
they want government control because
they believe that the government
will club the people they want clubbed
they believe that the government will
give them the things that they want
the government will do their bidding
it's
it's pretty insane it really is
and this is why you're seeing a
widespread celebration for example of
more and more government dependency
you're seeing a new perspective on the
left these days the new perspective on
the lesson
on the left is that inflation of the
economy is good that work shortages are
that labor shortages are actually good
because it's good that we're paying
people
to stay home after all why should people
have to work
after all why why shouldn't corporations
be punished by the government for no
apparent reason
lowering productivity increasing prices
why would that be bad
you know it's good that we're inflating
the currency because actually it's now
creating the intensive for people to
work less
there was an old bumper sticker that
used to be on a lot of cars back in the
1980s
work harder millions on welfare depend
on you that sort of
moved beyond being a cynical bumper
sticker and now has become almost a
democratic left left-wing slogan
bryce covert who is an independent
journalist
who has a p has a piece of the new york
times settled eight hours a day five
days a week is not working for us
okay this doesn't mean we should work
until we can afford not to work it means
the government should pass not to work
quote in truth the debate over the
return to the office is fraught
employers are used to being able to
dictate when and where employees work
but we have now discovered a lot of work
can be done at odd hours between remote
school lessons and from home offices or
even the comfort of one's bed
so now there's a push and pull over when
and how much work
people should start commuting and how
much power over the question employees
can exert
everyone is focused on how we will make
work work after such a severe shock to
the system for how things used to get
done
but the ultimate answer won't be found
in hybrid remote and in-person offices
or even in letting employees shift
around
their hours the way to make work work is
to cut it back
so your solution in the middle of a
labor shortage
is people should work less yes this is
going to make life better for everybody
when a country becomes rich enough
there's a simple tendency for a lot of
people to say okay you know what we're
all rich enough let's start
redistributing the wealth
right we're rich enough we don't need
any more growth we don't need better
products we don't need better services
you know we'll just stagnate the economy
and we'll just pass the money around
the problem is you're either moving
forward or you're moving backward when
it comes to an economy
economies that stagnate fall back
because there are competitors in the
world and those competitors are not
worried
about working 40 hours a week those
competitors have their people working 50
hours a week
it turns out in a globally competitive
economy you will not continue to earn
the same pay for your job
working 36 hours a week as you would
working 40 hours a week obviously
but the notion is that the government
should really continue to push people to
work less again
this is what's amazing they're siphoning
money away they are they're taking
control away
from people in the private sector
engaging in involuntary transactions
and they're moving it over to government
that is the goal and they'll do it
indirectly by
inflating the currency and paying people
to stay home
says the new york times columnist
there's a class divide and overwork in
the united states the demand to spend 60
hours in
office is one that depletes the lives of
professional higher paid workers what
would appear to be an opposite problem
plagues
those at the lower end of the wage scale
in 2016 about one-tenth of american
workers were working part-time
but trying to get more hours despite
current handwringing that these workers
are refusing to come back to the job
thanks to lucrative unemployment
benefits the problem is typically the
opposite
people who work in retail or fast food
often struggle to get enough hours to
qualify for benefits and pay their bills
just to survive you know one of the
reasons for that
is because people are being paid to stay
home people are being paid a myriad of
benefits
and you know what corporations do when
they see that you're being paid a bunch
of benefits they lower their wages
because you're getting paid from another
source this is not hard stuff
economically speaking
it is not difficult to understand if
everyone worked less says this new york
times columnist it would be easier to
spread the work out evenly to more
people
if white-collar professionals were no
longer expected or required to log 60
hours a week but 30
that would be a whole extra job for
someone else
no it wouldn't because it you know why
that company can afford to pay other
workers because somebody's working 60
hours a week in generating productivity
also jobs are not fungible some people
are better at them and some people are
worse at them
but this is what happens when you have
bureaucratically minded idiots
attempting to determine
who should work and who should not and
the predictable end result of that
is that you have less efficiency in the
economy less cool stuff
really people need to understand here's
the way the basic economics works
people create new innovation people who
take risks people who spend their own
money taking those risks to produce new
goods and services in ways people have
not thought of it before
those are the people who forward
economies if it were up to government
all you would get is slightly better
versions maybe
maybe over time of an old crappy
mousetrap
now henry ford famously said that if it
had been up
to other people most people when he
invented when he really
invented mass production of automobiles
in the united states he said
you know the the difference between what
i did and what a lot of other people did
is
if it had been up to other people they
would produce a more efficient horse and
buggy
it takes a difference in kind it takes a
different kind of mind to invent things
we used to have respect for inventors we
used to think that what they were doing
was actually amazing and cool
we used to idolize those people now it
seems that the people we idolize are the
people who seize wealth from those
people and punish those people
and treat those people as though they
are somehow expropriating wealth
rather than creating it which is totally
insane and counterproductive and
obviously makes life worse for millions
of people
the world over so frankly i think we
should be celebrating the fact that jeff
bezos went to space yesterday i think we
should be celebrating the fact that
richard branson went to space
i'd love to fly to space at some point
and the only way that's going to happen
is not by some government program the
only way that's going to happen is if
these three people
continue to compete at high levels and
continue to bring the price down on this
sort of stuff
that's when you're going to have the
opportunity to fly to space which by the
way could actually
wildly reduce the the time that you have
to travel for example
across the planet i could wildly reduce
the prices that you have
on other products space is a resource
the fact that americans are typically
leading that resource race is a very
very good thing and the fact that you
don't have to spend money on it
is an unabashedly good thing so i'm
if you couldn't tell i'm pretty
enthusiastic about all of this
and i think that everyone should be
enthusiastic as well it's a story of
american exceptionalism that we are able
to produce
so much wealth in this country via
products and services that people
voluntarily want to buy
that somebody can then take that and
then do something as cool as going to
space and reopening
an entire industry that was basically
moribund for the last couple of
decades pretty impressive stuff so
yesterday there was this big exchange
between rand paul and anthony fauci
the left has declared that that anthony
fauci won this exchange
and the right has declared that rand
paul won this exchange the entire
exchange
is over the question of whether the
national institutes of health
funded research in wuhan that could have
led to the
creation of the covet 19 virus
it is unclear at this point whether that
is true or not
what is true is that the united states
via the nih funded a place called
eco-health alliance which then gave a
grant
to the wuhan institute of virology they
were supposed to pledge not to engage in
gain of function research
but the question is what is gain of
function research
so there are a couple of different
definitions of gain of function research
that have been utilized one particular
definition suggests the gain of function
research
is a gain of function within viruses
that already apply to humans
another definition of gain of function
research is is a is a gain of function
for an animal virus that now is made
transmissible to humans
that's what this really comes down to is
a little bit of semantic word play here
now
nothing has we still don't know that
this came from a lab league
right it is very likely at this point
that it came from a lab league but we
still don't know
and we don't know exactly how that virus
was developed so a lot of this is
speculative
however it is certainly worth
questioning whether the
united states scientific community
should have been paying the wuhan
institute of virology at all considering
that we have no way
of actually seeing what it is that they
are doing
so here is rand paul and anthony patchy
going at it yesterday
dr falchi as you are aware it is a crime
to lie to congress
section 1001 of the u.s criminal code
creates a felony in a five-year penalty
for lying to congress
on your last trip to our committee on
may 11th
you stated that the nih has not ever and
does not
now fund gain of function research in
the wuhan institute of virology
and yet gain of function research was
done
entirely in the wuhan institute by dr xi
and was funded by the nih i'd like to
ask unanimous consent to insert into the
record the wuhan virology paper entitled
discovery of a rich gene pool of bat
sars related coronaviruses
please deliver a copy of the journal
article to dr fauci
in this paper dr she credits the nih and
lists the actual number
of the grant that she was given by the
nih
in this paper she took two bat
coronavirus
jeans spiked genes and
combined them with a sars-related
backbone to create
new viruses that are not found in nature
these lab created viruses within to
shown to replicate in humans
these experiments combine genetic
information from different coronaviruses
that infect
animals but not humans to create novel
artificial viruses able to infect human
cells
viruses that in nature only infect
animals
were manipulated in the wuhan lab to
gain the function
of infecting humans this research fits
the definition
of the research that the nih said was
subject to the pause in 2014 to 2017
a pause in funding on gain of function
but the nih failed to recognize this
defines in a way and it never came under
any scrutiny
dr richard e bright a molecular
biologist from rutgers described this
research in wuhan as
the wuhan lab used nih funding to
construct
novel chimeric sars-related
coronaviruses
able to infect human cells and
laboratory animals
this is high risk research that creates
new
potential pandemic pathogens potential
pandemic pathogens that exist
only in the lab not in nature
this research matches these are dr
ebright's words
this research matches indeed epitomizes
the definition of gain of function
research done
entirely in wuhan for which there was
supposed to be a federal pause
dr fauci knowing that it is a crime to
lie to congress
do you wish to retract your statement of
may 11th where you claimed that the nih
never funded gain of function research
in wujon
senator paul i can never lie
the question is pretty simple right
there okay so the question is
it's pretty obvious that we did actually
fund the wuhan institute of virology
that we said don't engage in gain of
function research but that we gained our
own definition of gain of function
research
and so what you're about to hear about
you respond is sort of the bill clinton
it depends on the definition of the word
is defense now from a legal perspective
he may be right right it may be why he
is going to avoid any sort of you know
criminal liability for example
because gain of function research can be
defined in a couple of different ways
on the one hand you can define gain of
function research as taking
animal viruses and mixing them with
other viruses in order to create human
pathogens
but there's a definition of gain of
function research that says really only
human viruses that are made more deadly
or more transmissible
only that is gain of function research
so that's the game that we're now going
to play it's a semantic game but the
underlying facts are really not in
dispute josh rogan
who is a columnist for the washington
post says rand paul is right
the nih was funding gain of function
research in wuhan but the nih pretended
it didn't meet their gain of function
definition
to avoid their own oversight mechanism
so here you're going to hear fauci get
very angry and play
word games here he goes
microphone your microphone senator paul
i have never lied
before the congress and i do not retract
that statement this paper that you were
referring to
was judged by qualified staff up and
down the chain
as not being gained a function
let me finish take an animal virus and
you increase this transability to humans
right you're saying that's not gain a
function yeah that is correct and
and senator paul you do not know what
you are talking about quite frankly and
i want to say that
officially you do not know what you are
talking about
okay you get one person let's read from
the ni
function this is your definition that
you guys wrote
it says that scientific research that
increases the trans military about
transmissibility among animals is gain
of function
they took animal viruses that only occur
in animals
and they increase their transmissibility
to humans how you can say that is not
gain a function it is not
it's a dance and you're dancing around
this because you're trying to obscure
responsibility
for four million people dying around the
world from a pandemic
and let's let's send doctor i have to
well now you're getting into something
if the point
that you are making is that the the
grant
that was funded as a sub award from
ecohealth
to wuhan created sars kovi
ii that's where you are getting let me
finish
we don't know wait a minute it didn't
come in the lab but all the evidence is
pointing that it came from the lab
and there will be responsibility for
those who funded the lab
including yourself i totally this
community will allow the
i totally resent the lie that you are
now propagating
senator because if you look at the
viruses
that were used in the experiments
that were given in the annual reports
that were published in the literature it
is molecularly
impossible no one's saying that it is
positive
it is those virus caused the pandemic
what we're alleging is
the gain of function research was going
on in that lab and nih funded it that is
get away from it it meets your
definition and you are
obfuscating the truth i'm not
obfuscating the truth you're the one
expired but i will allow the witness to
let me just finish i want everyone
to understand that if you look at those
viruses
and that's judged by qualified
virologists
and evolutionary biologists those
viruses are molecularly
impossible
of function viruses because there were
animal viruses that became more
transmissible and human
and you funded it and you admit the
truth and you implying
paul your time has expired and i will
allow witnesses who come before this
committee to respond
and you are implying that what we did
was responsible for the deaths of
individual
i totally resent that and if anybody is
lying
here senator it is you
okay so what are they actually fighting
about what they're actually fighting
about is definitions and fungibility of
money
so what is gain of function research
rand paul is saying gain of function
research is you take an animal virus you
make it transmissible to humans that's
gain of function
fauci is saying legally speaking really
it's only if you take a human virus and
make it more transmissible or more
deadly
that's gain of function that's a stupid
semantic game what we care about is
whether the united states
was in fact funding development of
viruses from animals
to humans that could have been
transmissible and deadly to other humans
right whether you call that gain of
function whether you don't call that
gain of function that is a bad thing for
the united states to be doing especially
at an institute where there have been
repeated reports of lab leaks at an
institute where the safety concerns were
serious
and under the auspices of a government
that is fascistic and communist in
nature
okay that's question number one question
number two is that the paper that rand
paul is citing
to talk about how they have been using
animal viruses in order to make them
transmissible to humans
that paper uses a specific subset of
viruses that it's investigating
and fauci is saying those viruses in
that paper
are not covid 19. the viruses in that
paper are molecularly impossible to be
covered 19.
and paul is saying i'm not saying that
the ones in this paper are covet 19.
i am saying this type of research could
have created coven 19 and that could
have leaked and we should have been
firing
we shouldn't have been funding this
institute in the first place
paul has the better of this argument he
does that doesn't mean that legal
liability is going to be attaching to
anthony fauci or that anthony fauci is
guilty
of some sort of perjury because perjury
requires an
intent to lie and it also requires that
you be legally untrue
and that's arguable and again found
she's sort of living in this gray space
here
what it does mean is that the united
states complicity in working
with the wuhan institute of virology
could create a
significant level of moral culpability
for the us government
we should not be working with scientific
institutions that run
under the auspices of terroristic
governments and i'm sorry the chinese
government is a terroristic government
it just took over hong kong and is
currently arresting editorial members of
apple daily
right now it is threatening taiwan
it is threatening the globe in a wide
variety of ways
ranging from internet surveillance
to belton road connections to
funding of of infiltrating groups in the
west
you know this is this is where rand paul
is exactly right
and the fact that we aren't willing to
look this in the face is pretty ugly and
what this really comes down to in the
end is how we see china
and until the united states starts
recognizing that china is an enemy the
chinese government is an enemy
not the chinese people the chinese
people have been subjected to tyranny
since
the the rise of mao the chinese
government is an enemy to the united
states and funding that enemy and
interacting with the enemy of the gover
this governmental entity is an insane
abdication of responsibility and that is
a bipartisan abdication
of responsibility does not live in one
party
okay meanwhile the left it continues to
push a narrative
that whatever happens with the rest of
this pandemic is now on the right we'll
get to that in just one moment first
how much equity do you have in your home
50 grand 100 grand more
cyber crime experts are alerting
homeowners the more equity you have the
greater the chance foreign and domestic
criminals will come after you
home title theft is one of the fastest
growing crimes in fact home title lock
america's leader in home title
protection is alerting homeowners they
could already be a victim and not know
it here's how it goes down first
cyber thieves search hundreds of public
databases for high equity homes
next they pull your home's online title
forge your signature stating you sold
your home
and take out loans at using your equity
you're not covered by insurance your
bank or
common identity theft of programs you
need to protect your most valuable
assets why would you not
protect your home title i mean that
really is your most valuable asset
protect your most valuable asset today
register your address now
see if you're already a victim receive a
complete title history of your home a
value free go to home title lock dot com
again that is home
title lock dot com uh it's something
that you don't think about until it
happens to you and god forbid somebody's
accessing
all of the asset value of your home
title against you
don't let that happen instead head on
over to home title lock.com
right now and register your address to
see if you're already a victim get a
complete title history
of your home for free right now alrighty
when it comes to freedom america is the
world's last hope
with lockdown protests getting
increasingly violence in london citizens
and business owners facing prison time
for disobeying vaccine passport laws in
france
is becoming increasingly clear we have
to fight to keep the last free country
free
that means standing up to the biden
administration's new call for censorship
across
all platforms for misinformation all of
this perfectly illustrates what i
predicted in my new book the
authoritarian moment it's a really
important book it hits shelves this
tuesday july
27th there's a lot happening right now
that i predicted the perversion of
science and the use of science
as a baton against the american people
the perversion of the educational
institutions via things like critical
race
theory i talk about all of this in the
authoritarian moment how institution by
institution
from your company to your kid's school
all these institutions have been
weaponized and militarized against
people who dissent
and more importantly how we stop all of
this go to dailywire.com
ben order your signed copy today at
dailywire.com i will be doing a live
stream to book signing event
next tuesday the 27th pre-order your
signed copy now when you do you'll be
asked to type in a question at checkout
then
catch tuesday's live signing see if i
answer your question watch me sign your
book get your copy at dailywire.com ben
right now also despite npr's latest hit
piece on daily wire where they covered
nothing but their own anger
and our success is a news organization
the daily wire is still
going strong by the way speaking of
which if you want a 25
discount off your subscription right now
at daily wire use code you mad
like literally umad because the npr they
are so mad at us they're mad at us that
we exist and that we're successful
they literally wrote a piece trying to
quash our traffic on facebook because
they admit we tell the truth
and we tell you that we're conservative
and they said that's why we should be
quashed
well the npr's mira campaign broke the
same day we released our brand new
podcast morning wire it is already
ranked at the top
of apple charts our listeners know
morning wire is a morning podcast that
values their time and the truth brought
to you by daily wire editor and chief
john bickley and co-host georgia howe
morning warrior will wake you up with
the latest developments in politics
sports culture and education all with a
heavy
emphasis on the facts it gives you
everything you need to know that's going
on in the world in like 15 minutes it's
available right now
subscribe to morningwire on apple
podcast spotify and everywhere you
listen
to podcasts so you don't miss a beat if
you like what you hear leave a five star
review help us keep delivering the news
you need to know you are listening to
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
meanwhile the statistics show that we
are nearing the end of this pandemic
okay realistically speaking we are
nearing the end of this pandemic because
the stat that matters is deaths the stat
that does not matter
is number of diagnoses no one cares how
many people in the united states for
example every year are diagnosed with a
cold you only care how many people die
from a particular disease yesterday in
los angeles
which is now requiring everybody to mask
up indoors it's a county of 10
million people 10 million the number of
people who died yesterday in los angeles
or recorded death via covet
was four four and this is true
day on day the average in l.a county
right now is somewhere between
two and six deaths okay every day
and it counts you have 10 million people
there's a solid case that you're
probably more likely to get shot in la
than you are to die of covet at this
point okay that
this is this is madness and it and it is
just insane i mean i talked
yesterday about the stat on this thing
the notion
that the delta variant in high
vaccination countries
is is going to shut everything down
again
all that is a political ploy and you're
seeing people there's certain people who
just
love the government being in control
there are certain people who are
desperate
for the government to be in control for
and it's not just in the united states
by the way there's a piece
by a woman named tanya gold a british
journalist writing for the new york
times
england is free and in total chaos
okay so it says tanya go quote england
is free we are told on monday the
government lifted the country's
remaining coveted restrictions on social
distancing on face masks on numbers for
gatherings at the lot
effectively leaving protection from the
coronavirus to vaccinations and the
goddess of chance
the timing was immaculate over the
previous week 332 000 people tested
positive for covid the most since
january as the delta variant courses
across the country
new covet 19 cases are expected to rise
perhaps reaching the dizzying figure
of a hundred thousand a day later in the
summer the number of hospitalized
much lower and in previous waves of
infections because of the vaccination
program
is steadily increasing deaths are
creeping up
okay now i am looking right now at the
number of uk
cova deaths and you can look at the
chart
according to the new york times
according actually to john hopkins
university
their latest covet data july 19 2021
the number of deaths recorded in all of
the united kingdom
was 19 19 at the height of the pandemic
they were losing somewhere on the order
of 600 people a day
how what 1700
people a day what what so we're now
losing
in the uk somewhere between 50
and 100 people a day it seems like on
average according to jhu
and this is requiring the entire
government
like this means boris johnson is bad
here's the here's the thing
what the elites want you to think that
people want is not what the people
actually want
tanya gold is a perfect example of this
she says confined to his countryside
residence johnson admitted
the cracked bondhummy the halting
obfuscation that is his trademark
because johnson has to self-isolate
because even though he has already had
copied and already he was vaccinated
he was um he was in close contact
with his health minister who's double
vaccinated and tested positive for covet
on saturday now here's the thing
if you are double vaccinated and you get
covered chances are you're not going to
get seriously ill you're not going to
die
these vaccines were not designed only to
stop you from getting the thing
they're designed to prevent you from
getting seriously ill and dying which is
what i care about if i'm asymptomatic
what the hell do i care whether i'm
diagnosed diagnosed positive with coven
but says this columnist the act
johnson's act successful for a season is
wearing thin
in the first week of july more than half
a million people were contacted by the
country's tracking service and told to
self-isolate for 10 days
creating chaos for businesses and
individuals alike
mr johnson's response was to early
excuse some key workers from
self-isolating
nevertheless he said we do need to stick
to the system as is
in johnson's england after all yesterday
is a lifetime ago
but this is the this is the part that's
hilarious okay this columnist
is really angry johnson saying that
johnson's botching this there will be
mass death in the streets
the conservative party led by boris
johnson now enjoys
a massive lead over its opponents the
conservative lead
over the labor party in britain is nine
percentage points
says tanya gold whatever the hair means
johnson's hair it's terrifying to think
we still do not know we're likely to
have a few more years to scrutinize it
but no matter what mr johnson says
nothing can dispel the sense we are a
country in decline
segwaying to crisis and then it turns
into all of these reasons why the
government needs to be bigger
and clover is just an excuse for why the
government needs to be bigger or maybe
or maybe the vaccines are a medical
miracle and the fact that so many people
who are vulnerable have already been
vaccinated is good
but it's the feeling of perpetual crisis
on behalf of political polarization
that is driving both lack of vaccination
and our political polarization
so for example if jay inslee as the
governor of washington state he is not a
very good governor
and and he says that trump voters are
the bioreactor facility spreading code
in washington now here's the question
if you actually wanted to convince trump
voters are unvaccinated to get
vaccinated
what you probably wouldn't do is insult
them what you wouldn't do
is say you are rube and a get
vaccinated
that is a tactic that never works ever
as ross doohan points out there are some
people who have already had covet and
they actually need some sort of
explanation of why they need to have a
vaccine
maybe there are people out there who
have serious doubts about the long-term
testability
especially given the fact that the fda
still is operating under emergency use
authorization
for these vaccines maybe acknowledging
people's fears
well suggesting that maybe in your
particular case you ought to ask a
doctor about your underlying factors and
your risk for covet
and then make a rational decision that
allows you to vexed
maybe that is the way to approach all
this but no this isn't about getting
people vaccinated
for democrats this is no longer about
getting people vaccinated for democrats
this has turned into
a way of once again clubbing people who
they don't like politically because
again
you know what the stats show you see
democrats are not yelling at black
americans for not getting vaccinated the
racial group in america least likely to
be vaccinated
is coincidentally the same racial group
in the united states that is most likely
to vote democrat
black americans you don't see democrats
ripping on them so this isn't about
whether people are good or bad for
vaccinating it's about whether you're
good or bad
for liking trump and not vaccinating the
vaccination is an excuse not to like
republicans
it's not that they don't like
republicans because republicans won't
vaccinate here's jay inslee doing this
routine
you're making a risk for everybody
around you when you don't get vaccinated
you're a risk for your spouse your risk
for your kids your grandkids your
parents
your coworkers because you are a
bioreactor facility
generating virus and spreading it around
including the kids who can't get
vaccinated
i want to reiterate that if you're a 50
year old man who
you know voted for donald trump and
didn't think covet was a problem and you
don't get vaccinated right now
you arrest every kid in your city
how are you a risk to every kid in your
city the number of kids total in the
united states who have died from code is
under 340. the number of kids over the
past year who have died of pneumonia is
over 800. no adult is a risk to every
kid in their city
i don't care if you're spewing kovid the
reality is that kids
are generally not harmed by the virus on
a statistical level
doesn't mean they can't be on an
individual level but on a statistical
level kids are very unlikely to suffer
grave harm from the virus
which by the way is the reason why only
45 percent of democrats with kids under
12 intend to vaccinate them as soon as
vaccine is available
45 of democrats because they're not that
worried about the kids
meanwhile again you can see the vast
disconnect between how democrats are
treated with regard to
spreading coven and and taking the
vaccine and how republicans are treated
by the media
here's jen saki yesterday who refuses to
call the texas delegation
which is now apparently infused with
covet like everyone on that plane
from texas the texas democrats who fled
they all got coveted apparently
here's jen's hockey saying that's not a
superspreader event it's only
superspreader when republicans do it
more than 10 of the traveling party with
these texas democrats
now claim to have a breakthrough case is
there any concern that this trip that
was intended
to advocate for voting rights is now a
super spreader event in washington
well i would say that's not a
characterization we're making from here
we certainly understand there will be
breakthrough cases even vaccines that
are
incredibly effective are not foolproof
they're not a hundred percent effective
we've seen that
well there's it's not a super spreader
event unless they're republicans
is this likely to get more people
vaccinated or is this just a political
tool for power and fun
at this point pretty obvious alright
we'll be back here later today with an
additional hour of content in the
meantime go check out the michael
knowles show today
he discusses twitter suspending marjorie
taylor green you can hear more details
about that story over on michael's show
that's available right now
i'm ben shapiro this is the venture
bureau show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover
production manager pablo wydowsky
associate producer bradford carrington
host producer justin barber the show is
edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
amazon founder jeff bezos goes to outer
space
texas democrats spread the woo flu on
their private jet booze crews
and a supermarket magnate warns of 10 to
increases in the cost of groceries by
october check it out on the michael
knowles show